berge so weit die augen sehen können
malerische täler und dörfer all das gibt
es in den alten für die
österreicherinnen katharina kurs
bedeutet wandern freiheit also wann dann
ist für mich irrsinnig schön weil diese
verbundenheit zur natur stattfindet man
bewegt sich draußen die ganze zeit und
in verbindung mit mit der tatsache dass
man einen weg selber geht man fertig
beim auto man fährt nicht nur im radio
wird nicht von elektronik unterstützt
von technik sondern man ist ganz bei
sich heute testet sie mit ein paar
anderen den neuen weitwanderweg alten
juwelen und die strecke verläuft von
garmisch partenkirchen in deutschland
über österreich nach südtirol in italien
der österreicher georg publisher hat die
route zusammengestellt die alpen juwelen
sind ein weitwanderweg auf leichten bis
maximal mittelschweren feldwegen und
sind aus weit wanderungen für einsteiger
gedacht
erster höhepunkt der tour die zugspitze
mit knapp 3000 metern höhe von
deutschlands höchstem berg genießen die
teilnehmer den blick auf mehr als 400
gipfel in deutschland italien österreich
und der schweiz
dann geht die wanderung am fuße des
berges erst richtig los nach ehrwald in
österreich auf der ersten tagesetappe
laufen die wanderer achteinhalb
kilometer
in den bergen müssen sie sich auf
kurzfristige wetterwechsel einstellen es
kann schneiden regnen oder heiß sein da
georg blatter seit rund 40 jahren in den
bergen unterwegs ist weiß er genau
welche kleidung wanderer benötigen
ganz wichtig ist die atmungsaktive
unterwäsche zum beispiel marino oder
kunstfaser etwas was sehr schnell
trocknet dann eine leichte wander hause
die ebenfalls bei wenn es regnen sollte
mal schnell trocknet und das wichtigste
sind die schuhe
die sollten auf jeden fall knöchelhoch
seien wasserabweisend zb mit gore tex
und eine gute profilsohle haben
nächster tag zweite etappe der alpen
juwelen zunächst geht es mit der
rheinbahn hoch auf 1500 meter heute
führt die route durch das geistal jetzt
wird es für die wanderer sportlich die
gesamte daten länge 15 halb kilometer
ungefähr viereinhalb stunden gehen
glaubt das sollten wir locker schaffen
wem das zu weit ist der kann sich zum
nächsten ziel mit einem auto bringen
lassen das gehört zum konzept natur und
auch schweres gepäck müssen die
teilnehmer nicht selbst schleppen sie
benötigen nur einen leichten rucksack in
den folgende dinge gehören für den
notfall ganz unerlässlich ein
vollständig geladenes telefon mit
eingespeicherten notfallnummern
zusätzlich sollte man mitnehmen eine
wanderkarte wo die route drinnen
eingezeichnet ist
außerdem wasser energiereiche snacks
sonnencreme ein erste hilfe set und
warme kleidung die alpen juwelen sind
auf sechs tagesetappen verteilt
insgesamt ist die strecke 76 kilometer
lang
da bleibt dem muskelkater nicht aus auch
nicht bei erfahrenen wanderern wie
katharina kurs
das anstrengendste in der heutigen
etappe war
als dann doch eine beträchtliche
steigung zu bewältigen war
da zieht es dann halt schon mal in den
waden oder in der ferse alle zwei
stunden nehmen sich die wanderer zeit
zum essen die strecke führt an
ausgewählten almhütten vorbei sie
servieren speisen wie zum beispiel
kachel eine gebackene tiroler
spezialität die man deftig oder süß
genießen kann
wandern ist gesund es stärkt die
abwehrkräfte und die muskulatur und
diese alpenüberquerungen ist auch für
kinder und senioren machbar
das grün wirkt wie wellness für die
seele hier haben wir einen traumhaften
blick auf die dolomiten das wäre das
schlimm
dahinter ist dann die rosengarten gruppe
in der mitte drin die violett türme und
ganz im hintergrund firma schon die
fahrer gruppe die schon im trentino
liegt die letzte etappe führt in den
organisieren dem italienischen südtirol
die pfarrkirche sankt genesius sieht man
schon von weitem
sie wurde im 16 jahrhundert gebaut
[Musik]
einige wanderer besuch noch die stadt
bozen südlich von medien sie liegt auf
gut 260 metern höhe